osama bin laden is
one of thousands of very radical
muslims it became their mission to
defend
afghanistan but then also to expand so
let's go to 911
you're 14 years old the event takes
place what's life like with the last
name of bin laden
brace yourselves because your life is
never going to be the same again
watching the news and some politicians
saying that you know islam is a religion
of peace
that politician you mentioned is a
president
all of the mainstream media perpetrated
that narrative
i would challenge any journalist go to
iran and work there for two years
christian amanpour should do what you
just said have you ever been to saudi
arabia you've never been
and then you have here in the west you
know mattel coming out with the veiled
barbie and
nike coming out with a hijab with a
swoosh and apparently you get labeled as
a racist
if you say these things but this
ideology is a real problem
let me get this straight there is
someone who is the niece of osama bin
laden who is a supporter of donald trump
he was able to bring all these people
together at the table
to strike peace agreements he hasn't
started any new wars
why do you think 80 million americans
voted for biden well first of all i
don't believe that number
you're supposed to hate trump we're
supposed to believe that this candidate
garnered more votes than hillary clinton
than
obama it smells really bad patrick this
incident in 1933 every muslim
needs to be aware of it and it is
something that is truly
shocking to hear
we need a welcome to the dean's show i'm
ed your host
good to have you back with us and it's
really good
to have our special guest dr kevin who's
with us i had to bring on an expert
somebody who's a scholar in this area
not only
are you your professor in the university
from the wisconsin
university you taught there for many
years in other universities
but you dwelled into an area also that
you became
a scholar technically in this area that
we're going to be discus
discussing and what prompted us to
discuss this
is that something is again being brought
to the surface
this topic of 9 11 with the
niece that all of a sudden came out of
the
woodwork her name is osama bin laden's
neat they're calling her osama bin
laden's niece
noor bin laden that's interesting
because i was telling you dr kevin
before i go on salaam alaikum how are
you
eddie it's great to be back on your show
i love your show peace be with you good
to have you
back again yeah thank you so did i hit
that right you were
a professor at the university of
wisconsin well close enough
i was technically a lecturer there uh
and i think well i forget what i was
categorized at edgewood college of
madison i was a professor
in milwaukee at kaplan university and
i've taught at san francisco state
and other places now just a recap
of your story because you're the
quintessential example of someone who is
exercising
his right to freedom of speech if i
remember that story correctly
and you were just blasted for that right
you were teaching critical thinking
skills
yeah remember how it was after 9 11
eddie it was crazy people were being
stampeded into this
fear kind of paranoia vibe sort of like
with covet today but with a lot less
reason because i do think there really
is such a thing as covid
and it's making people sick but 911 that
was a complete
um what should we call it uh stampeding
people into
totally unreasonable fear the chances
that you were going to get killed by any
kind of terrorist
and and most islamic so-called islamic
terrorists were being blamed for about
two percent of the attacks at the time
but the chance you'd be killed by any
kind of terrorist at that time or really
any other time
is comparable to getting hit by
lightning twice so that was a hoax but
everybody was terrified of the scary
scary radical muslims
and so i looked at this critically and
tried to teach critical thinking around
it and then in 2004
i woke up to the fact that the official
story of 9 11
was not just false but obviously and
easily
provably false so i started doing
activism
and teach-ins on that issue that got me
in trouble and then in 2006 i was
dragged on fox news attacked by
politicians made into a whipping boy for
the professors for 9 11 truth and
since then i've been forced to become an
independent scholar
and some would call me a professional
conspiracy theorist
now just you mentioned that word we
talked about this in previous shows
when this label is thrown out when did
this officially
get coined and when you
label someone with this term does that
kind of shut down the conversation
is that meant to shut down you know a
credible
you know conversation to just try to
ascertain the truth without going down
in a dark hole
well of course that's actually why the
term conspiracy theorist was popularized
by
none other than the cia it sounds like a
conspiracy theory but it is
a true one the cia issued
a memorandum in 1967 to its assets in
the media
and the cia has a lot of assets in the
media you can google the term operation
mockingbird for some of that evidence so
the cia put out a memo
and you can find this and read it on the
internet telling the editors publishers
and journalists that it owns and it owns
thousands
to start using the term conspiracy
theorist and start calling people
who were thinking critically about the
jfk assassination
conspiracy theorists the reason they put
this out in 1967
was that jim garrison the district
attorney of new orleans louisiana was
starting to prosecute
some of the people who killed president
kennedy and so
certain people in high places were
panicked and one of the ways they
reacted was by putting out this memo
to try to discredit critical thinkers as
so-called conspiracy theorists and
they've been using that trick
ever since now you mentioned something
like operation
operation mohawk was it called mocking
mockingbird sorry
operation mockingbird uh these are
things that you can go
look into and they're actually things
that were put together
uh they actually exist it's not
something you just because you hear this
term you know mocking but you
hear it but these this is actually
something that you can research and
is is out there operation mockingbird
was
maybe the most successful cia operation
of all time according to an
internal agency assessment they gave a
the highest medal to
the man who had done it a guy named cord
meyer
and then there's a whole angle with the
jfk assassin
assassination there that i won't get
into but yeah operation mockingbird
is undisputedly real and there's nobody
out there saying it didn't happen
and our biggest investigative
journalists have written about this carl
bernstein wrote
an article about how the cia owns
much of the mainstream media now there's
also
a muslim speaker out there he's someone
who's well known
in in america and worldwide he was
actually speaking
he he recommended it all muslims there
was a few
events in history and and one of his
speeches
we can uh let you hear it he was um
bringing these historical facts that
came up and this kind of ties in what
you know just current day events and and
then what we'll get to
this story with this uh newer
osama bin laden's niece who now is
getting the spotlight getting her 15
minutes of fame but let me show you this
real quick and then
uh if you can uh talk about these events
that this
uh this uh person is uh
his name is yasser cardi look up the
dreifus affair look it up d-r-e-y-f-u-s
where a person of a high position
who was of a jewish background was
accused of betraying the country
it turns out that they planted false
evidence
it turns out it was a false flag
operation tell us about this
that he this this event that he's
talking about the dreyfus affair
there was a jewish army officer named
dreyfuss
who was blamed for espionage on behalf
of germany
this was during the late 19th century
when france and germany were at odds
and it turned out that uh some i believe
the guy who was actually guilty of
espionage helped frame him
and so there was a big scandal at that
time there was a lot of
prejudice against jews i won't call it
anti-semitism because
european jews are not semitic
anti-semitism is prejudice against
semitic people which today is mostly
arabs and muslims but in any case
the dreifus affair was a huge scandal in
that for uh more than a decade there was
a fight
about whether this guy was guilty or not
he was actually sent off to devil's
island this horrific
prison and finally the forces people
like emil zola the famous novelist and
others
who were fighting for uh to vindicate
him uh finally succeeded
that he was vindicated and the culprit
was found but this this was a huge
scandal at the time
and it showed that people had rushed to
judgment when the and
that the authorities in france were
willing to blame a totally innocent man
just uh to make things convenient for
themselves and it would have
worked if it hadn't been for the heroism
of a number of people like zola
and we've there's many other similar
cases like this in history eddie
go ahead finish i'm going to get you
know the other one maybe before you
mention it
here this is the other one that this
muslim scholar he talks about that
everybody should
go back look into uh and know about but
there is two incidents again the the
dreyfus look it up
and the other one please look this up it
is called the reichstag
fire r-e-i-c-h-s-t-a-g the reichstag
fire
this incident in 1933 every muslim
needs to be aware of it and it is
something that is truly
shocking to hear the german parliament
was bombed
the parliament was bombed a fire was set
up
hitler immediately said the jews did it
instantaneously the public ran with it
the perception was
that this is a jewish plot and because
of this one
incident of bombing the parliament
hitler asked
and was given unilateral powers
like what happened 20 years ago in our
own country because of one terrorist
attack
you heard what he said that was yasir
khan he said every muslim needs to know
about these things
absolutely yeah the reichstag fire was
what it was the emergency
that allowed hitler to assume
dictatorial powers
and the deal was the german parliament
the reichstag was burned ostensibly by
some uh mentally [ __ ] uh guy named
van der lub but very likely the nazis
did it themselves but in any case they
used that pretext to seize absolute
power
and there's a parallel here eddie not
only with 9 11.
okay okay so now you see where i'm going
you see what we're trying to do we
talked about this term that's thrown out
okay all right so we talked about who
you are i mean first we're beginning
a you know an american patriot somebody
who's born here you weren't even muslim
at the time you were
just teaching your your your students
critical thinking skills you were
questioning the official narrative it
led you down a path to investigate
became a scholar in this area now
and then we all right now then we
brought up the point of
a muslim scholar here this yasakari who
talks about these events
uh even before that you you you
mentioned because this is
these are actual events that happen but
now
for you even to look into this if you if
you're you're scared because someone's
going to throw a naval
label at you you know a conspiracy
theorist and you get spooked and now you
just
believe all the official narratives but
he confirmed it
this is down if you go down history you
can see that these are facts that happen
but now we go back to what this lady now
we can come into this event that they're
trying to you know
again start to create this panic this
fear of muslims right through this
event this tragic event of 9 11. so now
if you look back and you see
how this was a definitely what he said
in his words a false flag
now you have things that are happening
like we're like they can't happen again
so go ahead sure well yeah 911 uh and
also the anthrax attacks which were part
of the same operation that together was
really a kind of american reichstag fire
because it allowed
the federal government to push through
emergency powers in the form of the
patriot act
and it wasn't just 9 11 itself that is
the attacks on the pentagon
and the entire world trade center where
every world trade center building was
destroyed with bombs
and none of the non-world trade center
buildings
right next to them were were totaled
uh and the pentagon was bombed but then
after
people were stampeded into this state of
paralysis and fear
based on that in the beginning of
october
these anthrax letters became known and
they s stampeded through the american
version of the enabling acts
which was the patriot act by sending
anthrax to the two democratic senators
who were trying to block
the patriot act and were interested in
investigating 911.
their names were tom daschle and patrick
leahy and they received anthrax in
envelopes
and scribbled on the envelopes were the
the words death to america death to
israel
allah is great so it was supposedly
another attack by by crazy muslims
and that shut down congress just like
the reichstag fire
did in germany and once congress was
shut down then when they reopened they
just went ahead and rubber-stamped the
patriot act
so there's a very close parallel there
the difference is that that time no
single dictatorial figure
emerged to become a permanent american
dictator george
w bush would have been a pretty pathetic
excuse for for a dictator
trump on the other hand uh he he would
be uh uh
perhaps more able to do that due to his
charisma and this kind of
hold he has over his followers so that
brings us into
now this emerging of
osama bin laden's niece now right so
she's been plastered on much of the
mainstream media now
um or some of these outlets now
she's done some interviews this one from
valuetainment is the one we're going to
just go ahead and
have you react to some of the things
that she's saying and i've watched some
of these
interviews that patrick's had from
valuetainment i mean he
has he's a good solid interviewer has a
good solid
program here but i'm just surprised now
because
much of the fake news out there they see
it as fake news
but they conveniently accept the fake
news when it comes to
islam right so that's the hypocrisy we
see here but let's get into this and
see what your thoughts this is her and
him censorship here in a minute
so let's go to 9 11. you're 14 years old
the event takes place
it happens um
you know you're watching the news and
names come
up osama bin laden your next last name
is bin laden
what what are you thinking at that
moment what's your mother's reaction
what are your two older sisters reaction
when you see that even taking place
so before all of that happens um
and we haven't touched upon this yet but
people i mean your viewers um
don't know this but i am a total patriot
at heart
like america after switzerland is my
second home
um the love for america was passed on to
me by my mother who really valued what
the country was built on
and she started taking me to the us two
to three times a year from the age of
three whenever
i'd have school holidays so by the time
i reached 14 years
old america was my second home
um so much so that you know two years
before 9 11 i had gotten a u.s flag
on holiday in south carolina and it was
you know on my wall in my room
and i would get teased so much in school
what do you think this is again i mean
it it's the whole model never forget
nissiki's being brought up
you know uh you heard the new model that
we
that has been brought out never forget
islam and muslims had nothing to do
with 9 11 stop using us as the scapegoat
but it seems like again
here we go again the re-emergence and
the fear-mongering
is being united what do you think when
you when you when you hear this topic
again being brought up
in this way with her now all of a sudden
well i could see
even you know back when i realized what
911 and anthrax
really had been i could see that it was
going to keep on
uh continuing as this propaganda thing
for a very long period
and sure enough i'd even discovered that
one of the men
who's most likely involved in scripting
the entire 911 drama because it was
undoubtedly scripted in advance
with the idea of creating the effect
that it created and one of the people
who's suspected of being involved in
that
is a man named dr philip zeliko he's a
history teacher at
university of virginia and uh he
published an article
in foreign affairs magazine in 1997
speculating on what would happen if
there were a
spectacular kind of pearl harbor style
attack on the united states such as the
destruction of the world trade center
and he at the time in 1997 said that
what would happen
is that it would divide time into a
before and after and nobody would
remember what things had been like
before this
catastrophic event and uh he said that
it would
create a a multi-generational effect
sort of sort of like pearl harbor did
there were
focus group studies that showed that
americans still hated japanese people as
late as the 1990s because of pearl
harbor
so zelika studied that and said there
would be a multi-generational hatred of
islam
if the world trade center were destroyed
in a terrorist attack basically
he didn't quite say it in those words uh
but it was close enough
in that article he published in 1997
with john deutsch
uh called imagining the catastrophic
event so
this is this guy celica who was then
made the head of the 911 commission and
he ran the 911 commission completely he
had
total control over the entire thing and
he scripted the entire report
before the commission had even convened
in fact he wrote the entire report in
chapter outline
before the commission had even convened
to investigate the event so
uh the point being that this was
designed to create this long-term effect
and to keep on going
for a hundred years or more it's going
to keep pushing uh western people
like noor bin laden westernized people
in her case to hate islam
for generations to come it's interesting
that her name i mean she
paints herself i mean i love america i'm
you know i love my country right
we might not agree with some things we
that
are perpetuated in the name of you know
like
drone attacks killing innocent people
and another where like muhammad ali when
he came out and he didn't refuse to go
and
to fight poor people in another country
for killing poor people right he stood
up and now he's he's a muslim american
hero
so again what does that mean it's just
put out there she's paying like she's
got she's
she's got this uh flag you know she's in
switzerland and just
it's kind of like this she's trying to
appease to the emotions of people as
as if the american people are that
credulous you know they're just that
gullible
and to fall first for for these stories
i mean if you look at her name she feels
she looks um as though now she couldn't
because her mother's
name was uh her mother's name is carmen
dufour or something right
we know in arabic i mean if you look at
osama bin means the son of
right so if you translate her nur this
the son of
uh why she could have just easily just
taken her she's not
practicing doesn't she's like she's not
a practicing muslim she hates like islam
she could have easily if she was that
scared you know just took her mother's
name or just latin i mean it's not she
don't why is she saying bin the son of
you know so it just doesn't add up it
just seems like this is all just
set up you know for some uh some
nefarious agenda
well that was my first reaction when i
saw this uh this she seemed so
kind of plastic and out of central
casting that i wondered if did
walt disney had made her you know the
way they make the hall of presidents
they'd created bin laden's niece for us
but
yeah i she maybe she should change not
only her last name bin laden as you say
that means son of so
what what what does that mean but noor
of course means light
it's the famous
god is the light of the heavens and the
earth uh it's a beautiful name
seriously she's uh you know i think
she's she must have been horribly
traumatized by this assuming she's real
and she's not out of the hall of
presidents which i
am willing to assume she would have had
a
tough time when she was 14 years old 9
11 happens
and she has this link to the alleged
perpetrator or the fall guy or the patsy
or what have you
and just like so many other muslims and
not just muslims but you know sikhs were
getting shot and lynched
because they looked sort of muslim so
there was that hatred of muslims that
9 11 was designed to create and she was
right there in the middle of that
storm and it must have really terrified
her as a little kid and
so that must have traumatized her to the
point
that she reacted by waving her american
flag it's funny the way she said i'm
such a
such an american patriot after
switzerland it's my first country well
a lot of american patriots would say
after switzerland
well yeah and of course that's almost as
bad as after israel
and of course that's very common after
israel america is my first country
that's what about half of our government
and most of the people that own our
media and give most of our money to
political
campaigns that's how what they would say
if they were telling the truth uh
yeah i love america it's my second
favorite country after israel
but in any case she is uh i think she's
the walking wounded you know because
i think she's real i think she really is
bin laden's niece
and she reacted to this trauma by waving
the american flag harder than everybody
you know i'm more american than anybody
i really i didn't do it please don't
lynch me
and that's the way she's identified for
her her whole life
and now she's had this opportunity to
come into the limelight
waving that flag as hard as she can um
on behalf of donald trump which
it's it's actually you know it would be
hilarious if it weren't so pathetic
now i like patrick actually from this
evaluation he brings on some good guests
you know covers some good topics but and
i hope this reaches him and he can just
reevaluate when it comes to now when
people go out of their lane i mean he
promotes reading books i mean read the
quran i mean for yourself
hook up with the muslim have someone
like you who's a scholar in this area in
this area
of 9 11 of many of these things that
they're bringing up
uh to bring on someone like you right to
ascertain really for his audience what's
fake and what's real and and and it's
sad that now they're i don't see really
any good behind this it's just
this fear-mongering right so let me go
ahead and
share another clip here from this and
get your reaction we just had the
election and i know you
you were on tucker and a few different
shows and you
express your support for uh uh
trump see over here osama bin laden's
niece says only trump can prevent
another 911.
but what magazine just came out last
week calling him president
okay so see again another but doesn't
share like uh
you mentioned as another scholar someone
who's written extensively on this can
you elaborate doctor
he's a christian who was searching for a
true doctor
was it david ray griffin yes so he blows
all that out
of the water this whole 911 being linked
to islam and muslims
yes david ray griffin is a professor
he's retired
now who has written about 12 books on
911
starting with the new pearl harbor and
his work
is totally indispensable if you really
want to get into the nitty-gritty of
what happened it didn't happen
and especially what's his name again
david ray griffin david
ray griffin so if patrick or her or
anybody who's sincerely looking for the
truth in this matter this is an academic
he's a christian also he's not muslim
and there's a quote that he said that
the evidence that you know has
seems has been fabricated that's trying
to link islam to muslims you know that
famous quote that he made
uh you know i don't remember that
particular quote but it's just
stunning how much of the so-called
evidence
around 9 11 was obviously fabricated
you know i won't get into all the
details but like the only reason that
they
pointed a finger at mohammad ada was
that otta had two magic suitcases that
were magically discovered
full of planted evidence that the cops
knew was planted in the case of one of
them
and i mean i could go on about the
planted evidence why don't we stick to
something just simple simple when
somebody looks at this
many people don't know uh that one of
those buildings seven
nothing even hit it right yeah if you
want the simple version it's simple yeah
the simple version of how you know that
911 was a false flag
just investigate the controlled
demolition of building 7.
the official story is that building 7
fell down at 5 23 in the afternoon due
to
some very minor office fires uh that
would be the first time in history
well the third time because of the two
towers that a steel-framed high-rise
office building
has ever completely uh collapsed
for any reason other than controlled
demolition but with building seven
just look at it it's obviously a
demolition uh
as essentially everyone is admitted even
the the go-to scientists who
tried to come up with ways of imagining
that the towers
had not been blown up you show them
building seven
and they basically shrug and throw up
their hands the only people
upholding the official story about
building seven which is that it just
fell
down from office fires uh those people
are basically
on the government payroll so people
say okay eddie like why are you talking
about this topic i mean
these topics are being brought up and
they keep we have to go to the root of
the matter because they keep again using
islam and muslims as a scapegoat we know
that islam condemns something like this
i mean you don't have
a justification but they're trying to
you know show otherwise
but then when you have the whole event
is questionable right
then and and if somebody uh looks into
it and that's why we brought someone
like yourself an academic a scholar in
this area who can also who's pointed to
other uh academics and uh investigators
and people you have like 3 000 plus
almost 4 000 architects and engineers
richard gage i believe is his name
someone like him who gives a
presentation
and asks hundreds of people in the room
how many of you believe this
at the start but after he presents the
evidence all hands are down you know
so what do you think well yeah the one
thing about 911
that everybody can figure out pretty
quickly if they look into it is that the
world trade center was demolished with
explosives
it didn't just magically disappear you
know in these
gigantic explosions because it had been
hit by planes with a little bit of
kerosene or jet fuel enough
the official story is of course that
that kerosene in the planes
started office fires and the office
fires destroyed the buildings
but once you look at this beginning with
building seven you'll quickly figure out
that obviously these buildings were
destroyed with some very very powerful
explosives precisely how that was done
is still being debated
but once we don't have to get into that
right i mean that's not for us to figure
that's when you start
you know someone labels you that name
conspiracy theorist you're trying to
theorize put it together that's not our
business okay whatever
how would happen when it i mean how
would happen this down the other okay oh
maybe
at the end only god almighty allah at
the end maybe in jannah you can
go ahead and watch it in uh right 4k or
whatever
but see the what this means though is
that they had rigged up these huge
buildings for demolition
ahead of time in advance these uh even
building seven which was only
47 stories and the two towers were all
like 110 stories so
the even building 7 at 47 stories was
the tallest building
ever taken down in the controlled
demolition at that time
so these were huge complex jobs
very very difficult and they had to have
been rigged up in advance
and so what that means is that when they
blame
supposed muslim hijackers and we have
every reason to know that there were no
muslim hijackers that day
but uh even just how would they have
trusted
people to uh to hit these targets
and somehow uh you know create the
pretext for blowing them up
so they they would not have allowed
people to just randomly hijack planes
and fly them into buildings to
provide that pretext instead they would
have used remote control or some
some means to make sure that there was a
plane crash that then they could blame
the uh demolitions on that that means
there were no muslims on the plains
and there's all kinds of evidence to
show that these 19 guys that they blamed
for this
were not on those planes at all and that
most likely the best hypothesis
is probably there were planes flown by
remote control but what about the
300k study from
alaska university is it yeah that's uh
leroy helsi is the professor at the
university of alaska fairbanks who has
put out
the definitive final scientific word on
building seven
and it's it's kind of belaboring the
obvious it's
it's very obvious to anybody with basic
sort of
grade school or maybe middle school
physics that
this building building 7 couldn't
possibly just come straight down
at almost free fall acceleration because
of some office fires
because to to have it come down like
that straight into its footprint at free
fall
you would have to remove all of the
vertical supports exactly at the same
moment
you know if you missed if you got most
of them but not a couple of them boom
it's going to topple
you know a big tall building like that
always wants to topple like a tree you
know you can't take a tree and turn a
tree into a little pile of sawdust on
the stump
very easily and so so that's why they
pay uh
control demolition firms so much to
bring them straight down so everybody
looks at building seven can see
that it was a demolition however if you
want to get into the nitty gritty
of absolutely proving it beyond any
possible doubt and showing why the
government's
uh explanation is as insane as it is
you can do what professor hulsey did and
do a really complex computer modeling
study
and so that's available for anybody who
wants to really get into the engineering
details
how do you um advise people who
know they don't believe the official
narrative and that's
all someone is saying like oh there's
things that are questionable like things
right in front of your eyes this wasn't
like a houdini or a um
magician trick you know that or was it i
mean that this building just
fell down nothing hit it but someone
when you're talking to people
and you're explaining you know what
islam is you know
submission to the creator not the
creation you know jesus practice it
uh moses abraham it's a way of
connecting with your creator the one and
only
and you go into the beautiful tenets of
it but then in the back of someone's
mind or someone even comes out say but
you guys are the guys right your
religion it's because of muslims that
now
again it's always there so and now it's
being revisited again with this
scripted play that seems like it's
coming up so for someone who's a novice
in this area
what do you and then usually the
arguments are look which is fact that
islam doesn't uh condole us it condemns
it right and
they weren't muslims who did it right
but somehow they
they you know it was muslims but if they
weren't practicing islam and then you
get into all this but when you get to
the root of matter
islam and muslims had nothing to do with
it so what advice would you give to
someone where
you don't because people are scared to
come off like and get labeled a
conspiracy theorist
well if you can if you have the time to
do some reading and look into it
and then you can you know learn some of
the facts about it
i'm just telling people about those
facts i guess is about the best you can
do
yeah because it's it's not unfortunately
the problem is
that a traumatic event like this uh and
this nur bin laden is a
classic example of somebody who's been
traumatized into
becoming very defensive and and being
very rigid in a particular
approach you know so she's waving her
american flag
and and you know screaming against islam
uh but she's just an extreme example
because about
half the american people were given
pre-traumatic stress disorder by the
tv images they saw on 9 11. and this is
an example of
what the professionals in this field the
word professional is a little dubious
here they would call this
uh traumatic uh mind control or
or you know using trauma to uh to
brainwash people
when people are traumatized they become
sort of desperate and they don't have
anything to grab onto
and so then the person who's trying to
brainwash them can basically
tell them anything and the person will
internalize it at a very deep and
often unconscious level so the there are
so many people walking around today with
this uh hatred or sort of negative
feeling and fear of islam
that's been implanted deep in their
subconscious mind by
this 911 operation which was designed
precisely to do that and we have to find
ways to disarm them
and there are all sorts of ways you can
sort of de-program and disarm people
i think humor is helpful sometimes i've
been doing this kind of work
educating people about these kinds of
very frightening things
for 15 years now and i think a little
bit of humor can be helpful i mean not
not tasteless humor but uh just
lightening up a little bit so we can get
some distance
and rethink um our kind of basic
reactions to things
like if you had this this muslim scholar
who uh yasakari who
who brought up this event in history
that happened
where hitler he ended up starting the
fire bombing his own
parliament was it yeah setting fire to
the reichstag
parliament yeah so why is it hard to
believe now why is it like far-fetched
that the same thing happens in 20 and
and in modern day
right well false flag operations are
very common and
in 2001 nobody heard of them except for
people in military academies where they
are taught as part of the curriculum
false flag operations are they're very
common that happened throughout history
the expression comes from when
a naval ship would hoist the flag that
wasn't its own flag to try to you know
attack somebody and get somebody else
blamed for it
and to this day criminals uh
serious criminals organized crime types
will
often find a patsy who will be blamed
for their crime
because they know that most police just
want to
solve the crime and so you throw the
patsy to the police
and patsy gets blamed and perhaps
convicted or maybe silenced before he
can be tried
and then the case goes away uh so
framing people setting people up for
things they didn't do
tricking countries into thinking they've
been attacked by somebody uh
to to start a war i mean this is this is
old hat
and you know just let me give you a
couple of examples um israel is a
specialist at this
in 1954 they attacked the united states
uh attacked american and british targets
in egypt this was called the lavon
affair
and people can look this up yeah what's
it called affair l-a-v-o-n
and for many decades israel insisted
that no this was just an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory and the egyptians who
convicted these israeli terrorists
uh had had convicted innocent people but
then uh
i think about 15 or 20 years ago the
israeli government finally admitted that
yes we did it
and then they gave medals to everybody
who was involved then in 1967 another
even bigger israeli false flag was the
attack on the uss liberty spy ship
this was during the 1967 war and the
israelis attacked it
all out trying to murder more than 300
american sailors on this unarmed spy
ship
they repeatedly returned to strafe
lifeboats
they tried to sink it uh and only by
allah's grace
was that ship saved 34 american sailors
ended up dead
uh and hundreds wounded uh almost
everybody in the ship was wounded
but then afterwards the u.s and israeli
governments hushed it up
the reason was that it was a false flag
it was supposed to be blamed on egypt
they were going to
kill 300 american sailors and then
the americans were going to say oh egypt
did this and then america was going to
jump into the war
and bomb russian bases in egypt which
might have started world war three
so that's just yeah and there are
hundreds of examples of these false flag
operations
so people need to educate themselves if
people had actually known about these
things before
9 11 they probably couldn't have done
911 and
not only those 3 000 people would still
be alive but
many millions around the world who've
been murdered in wars that were
triggered by 9 11 would also still be
alive which you had many muslims
actually also
who died in 9 11. yes there were muslims
who died in the towers
there were people from all sorts of
countries um
the again the luckiest country was
israel which had a huge presence in the
towers but they all moved out a week
before
zim shipping lines which is co-owned by
this government of israel and the
rothschilds
broke its lease losing a huge amount of
money to move out
one week before 9 11 and then odigo
instant messaging system sent out a
warning in hebrew that morning
warning people to stay away from
downtown manhattan
so the israelis only lost a couple of
people
but countries i forget which countries
but if you look you can look at the list
all sorts of countries lost double
figures worth of people including muslim
countries and there were muslim
americans who died as well
what happened to the the janitor was he
called the last man
out he was someone who actually ended up
accepting islam
he wasn't muslim he helped actually
everybody he had like the key
for the utility rooms what was his name
that's william rodriguez
he was the last man out of the north
tower last man dived under a
truck uh as the whole building came down
whatever happened to him
well last i heard uh he's alive and well
and a family man in new york he spent
many years on the lecture circuit
he first he he was a national hero for
saving people you know he helped the
fire department save
a lot of people before he got out yeah
and so he was a national hero he met
bush and so on and
then he kept trying to give his
information to the authorities and he
actually did testify but
before the 911 commission and he
testified that huge explosions had
badly injured people and done tremendous
damage
to the lobby and the lower levels of the
towers
before the plane hit and
uh and then huge explosions were going
off uh after that in the towers as well
as he was helping the fire department
save people so anyway he wanted to
testify about this
but unfortunately the 911 commission
sealed his testimony
top secret it's never been seen and that
showed him that there was something
really wrong and so since then you know
he
began doing lectures he did a lot of
lectures for several years
and now i think he's retired from the
lecture circuit and i'm not quite sure
what he's up to isn't that interesting
he was getting all the mainstream
media attention when when they were
using him to kind of
go with the narrative but as soon as he
came out with the truth and the reality
what happened
they went opposite to that he got
silenced and then he had everything he
could have went along with that ride
and he could have made more money right
but he went the opposite
right yes he became an unusual uh kind
of 911 hero
but i think it you know he was he's he's
really a very admirable guy and it was
amazing it was by the grace of allah
that this guy a good-looking articulate
janitor
happened to be there with the only key
to lead the firemen up
and uh you know to open up the the
stairways uh and get people out and then
to survive it it's just a quite a
miracle
what do you say when people they talk
about how
insensitive someone is being because of
the family members to even talk like
this
well a family members i know people like
bob mcelveen who lost his son bobby
in the north you know some actual family
members of course sure i've been working
with them for more than ten years you've
been working with the family members of
911
family members of 9 11 know a lot of
them
uh really you know know that the
official story is false
um bob mcelveen uh and it's really sad
to hear him say this he's come on my
radio show
several times and he he investigated
very closely to find out what happened
to his son
and he knows his son was uh killed uh by
blunt force trauma uh from explosions
his son was there in the lobby
before the plane hit and and those same
explosions that willy rodriguez talked
about
uh presumably killed him and so bob
knows that and he's been trying to get
justice for his son
for 15 years now and he he and many
other
family members of the victims are behind
the various
lawyers committee for 9 11 justice and
the architects and engineers for 9 11
truth lawsuits there are a number of
lawsuits going on
and then there's matt campbell uh and
jeff campbell i think is jeff
i think matt campbell was the one who
who died and his brother jeff over in
the uk
is pursuing justice in the uk he's got a
court action in
in the uk about this so there are lots
of family members who've been working
for justice on this ellen mariani was
another one
who sued bush and cheney for killing her
husband who was on one of the flights
a long history of activism the the film
911 press for truth was made by the
jersey girls the most famous of these
uh victims family activists so it's an
insult to these victims
survivors to say that they shouldn't be
allowed to find out why their loved ones
really died
and who did it i've also heard that
us there was more people who were
calling in
they were calling in and investigating
like calling mosques
many people were also buying up
more qurans than ever after that i heard
because they wanted to know like
people who really who were out genuine
they wanted to see like does islam
really teach this
even though we dismantled everything
with these facts out there but
uh people who wanted to know like okay
what is islam all about
and and during those times that people
were
reading the quran and they were saying
hold on they were going to the source
so why don't these people like patrick
we uh sincerely ask him to
get a good translation of the quran read
it for her also read the quran for
yourself
it seems like they conveniently just you
know don't want to do that why is that
and then you had people who were doing
that and they were actually accepting
islam you had more people accepting
islam
actually after 9 11. yeah it's by the
grace of allah some people
approach things with an open mind and
look into islam and others don't
looking at patrick and nour in this
conversation i found this
conversation kind of power painful and i
think that maybe part of the reason for
that is that both of those two people
are in pain and you know they clearly
were in pain when they were talking
about their parents divorces
i mean both of these people have
experienced trauma in both cases their
parents divorced when they were kids
and it left uh you know left a trauma
for them and you can see that on their
faces when they talk about that
and of course newer bin laden talked
about the trauma of being a you know kid
when 9 11 happened and
you know kind of getting blamed for it
so these people i think are are
kind of in pain and patrick comes from a
family that fled iran
during the islamic revolution and so
apparently his family was on the other
side the anti-islam side during the
revolution
and so his family are exiled from the
islamic republic of iran
and that pain of exile probably came to
him at least second hand
and so i i think these people have
become kind of rigid
in their approach to things uh by as a
way to defeat this pain that they're
suffering from
and how to heal them you know maybe
maybe the quran actually could help heal
them
i don't think there's anything as
healing as salat prayer
and as reading quran if you get to the
point where you can read and recite
quran which
alhamdulillah i've been able to do that
now for a couple of years i'm following
sheikh imran hussain's method of doing a
full
quran recitation you read it aloud every
day from
and in one month you finish it and he
has a whole method
people can go to imran hussain's website
to learn how to do that
it's very very healing you know it's for
me it's been
very painful actually having to deal
with the
reality of 911 which is even uglier and
more terrifying than the official
version
and then that's led me into having to
look at many other
things that most people would rather not
look at things like trauma-based mind
control
you know 911 was one example of
trauma-based mind control
but you know look at look up project
monarch
look look up um mk ultra
the there are criminals and intelligence
agents
who intentionally traumatize people uh
in order to
control their minds this is just one of
the kinds of subjects i've
ended up studying after i was forced out
of the academy
for getting looking into 911 and
so i think that the the healing power of
islam
and islamic practice in particular the
actual ritual practice of letting go of
everything
surrendering completely to god as you
put your forehead on the floor
uh it's it's the highest form of call it
meditation
call it thanking god or praise or prayer
whatever you want to call it
salat is an amazing thing with this
great healing power and so i pray that
people like this who've suffered
from these various kinds of pains and
traumas in their lives that
have led them to hate and to reject and
to push away
their uh their real heritage and their
real
relationship with god you know god's
waiting for them and so all they really
need to do
to really heal is to stop you know stop
hating on islam and waving your flag
extra hard and
and yelling that you're you know in
favor of trump or whatever
and and just let go and and uh and and
face the truth i'll huck which is
another name for for god in
in our tradition and these people really
could be healed by islam
whether that happens or not i guess i
guess allah and they are
you know the ones who determine that if
they can get past all the
fake news that's out there and the
misinformation
and we'll end off with this there's one
more thing
that from the clip
i can't stand the veil you know and then
you have here in the west you know
mattel coming out with the veiled barbie
and
nike coming out with nike coming out
with them
hijab with a swoosh and and knowing
you know what's happening in uh
in the middle east and and these women
who are being persecuted it's just
we'll finish it off from from there you
can see just she's uh she's
boiling like her body language says it
all and then she has a letter
uh to america and and part of it she
talks about some things that if
she would look into it patrick would
look into islam
i mean you you articulate articulated
you know the the healing effect of the
quran and then
if they looked at and put it to the test
who the quran actually came from
like it's from the creator of the
heavens and earth the creator that
created you and then she talks about the
veil now
and if she i believe it comes off as
she's
christian i believe the bible says in
like men are old
and like men also that women are doing
themselves in
modest appearance what is so modest
about this uh because she mentioned
in her letter but you have jesus the
mother mary who's wearing the hijab so
she's talking about this about modesty
and she's talking about the degeneracy
of the moral
of the breakdown of the family but this
is all what islam comes to preserve the
family
modesty morality worship of one and only
god the same god of jesus moses abraham
the last defilement prophet muhammad
peace and blessed be upon him paul
so it's like kind of you know these
double standards of hypocrisy like this
is everything that you're
she's talking about about family about
you know
morality all these this is the essence
of islam about building a
society based on justice of good
character manners you know
so when you hear that and then she's and
then the whole thing about hating the
veil
but jesus's mother she wore the veil the
hijab
yeah well you know again she experienced
the painful you know
divorce of her parents when she her
father was saudi and
and muslim and her mother was swiss and
apparently non-muslim
and i think that really hurt her and of
course when you're a kid you're gonna
identify with the parent that you that's
taking care of you you know you have to
almost so
i think she identified with that you
know non or anti
uh muslim side of her own family split
and uh so why does she hate the veil so
much
uh and and mischaracterize it as
something that women are
forced to do when in fact in reality for
the most part hijab
is a voluntary choice that women make to
express
their spirituality and and their purity
it's a kind of a
it's a it's a symbol that i'm a
spiritual and pure being you know don't
put your
uh your desiring eyes on me you think
the feminist would actually like that
but
for some reason they seem to uh prefer
it the other way but
but then the irony here is that that
family breakdown that she experienced
and that patrick experienced and that so
many kids from this generation are
experiencing
this comes from the breakdown of the
kind of morality
that islam is there to preserve and so
it's really the solution for these
problems and these two people would be
experiencing a lot less pain
if they had grown up in a genuinely
pious kind of islamic milieu
so i just wonder how many people in this
generation these young people like this
who grow up kind of you know hating and
into identity politics and
decadence and depravity or whatever
they're into and it
leads nowhere are someday going to get
out of the vulumat and back towards the
nor out of the darkness back towards the
light
and noor here uh she's a candidate for
that
so it's patrick you know they both came
from muslim backgrounds now they're
self-hating muslims
right you know there's a joke about the
self-hating jews oh if you don't like
israel you must be a self-hating jew
well i mean i don't know about that but
these two are definitely self-hating
muslims they hate the muslim side of
themselves and they've been trained to
and they've been brainwashed to hate the
muslim side of themselves but
by 9 11 by the particulars of their
divorce where the non-muslim parent gets
custody and
hate that darn muslim dad of mine and
you know it's it's it's
very very sad but there is that solution
still there
if people get back to that traditional
god-based morality where there's
actually a divine reason
to be moral if you're an atheist there's
no reason
why it's better to be moral than immoral
really right it's all the world's a
random accident
if you're pious and you know that god
actually is watching and you're going to
be judged
and you can feel that presence of allah
and the angels around you
you have the best of reasons to be moral
and virtuous and when people
are moral and virtuous their families
don't break up and this kind of pain
doesn't happen yeah so wrapping up here
um one more thing i hate when they
mentioned this uh
you caught it in the interview um the
term akafir right
yeah they pronounce it kefir yeah is the
the milk actually the probiotic milk
that you're right right
yeah yeah well obviously nur bin laden
doesn't speak any arabic
yeah she said you're familiar with the
term kefir
like and accentuating the word fear in
the second syllable
was quite uh telling um but yeah she
obviously knows nothing about islam she
just
she hates on it so much that she hasn't
bothered to learn about it but this term
that was coined because they try to
translate that
as uh infidel which there's this is
uh this is wrong because kaffir it means
to cover up the truth
ungrateful truth concealer but this uh
infidel was coined by the christian
crusaders
right yes that's the word infidel that's
that's an english word that the
crusaders use so they're projecting out
of the muslims their own feelings
and then uh we advise i mean i sincerely
humbly advise patrick he's read so many
books
read a good translation of the quran
there's a clear quran.com you have sahih
international
i don't know if you one particular you
think is good
same thing for her meet go uh visit a
mosque
ask your questions come to the source
you know come
and sit with muslims and instead of
creating this
anxiety and fear in people which uh is
is not
going to create peace in the world uh
you're just helping to
create more problems so you said it
beautifully
the quran is a healing effect uh read it
right and then what would you advise for
muslims out there who have kind of gone
away
because god almighty allah tells us if a
fascic if a evildoer someone comes to
you with this
verified check it up right so we see uh
the community is home and even many
muslim scholars i mean how would you
advise critical thinking especially in
this day and age
yes that famous verse from the quran is
sometimes translated as ascertain the
truth if the facet comes to you with
alarming news
ascertain the truth or you might regret
what you did you know if you react
the wrong way and i think as muslims we
should be regretting the fact that when
the fast
fassic media and the fafsa government
came to us with this alarming news about
oh the muslims just blew up the world
trade center with a couple of planes
we should have ascertained the truth
before we went along with it but most of
us just sort of went along with it
uh we we shouldn't we should we should
be aware
that we're living in a society that is
it's not
uh an open free democracy with a free
media we're living in a controlled
corporatocracy
or a plutocracy ruled by the rich they
run the media
uh what you're getting in the meat in
the mainstream media is
not anything even remotely close to the
real
overall you know accurate reflection of
what's really going on in the world it's
propaganda
just like in the old soviet union what
we're getting here is really no more
accurate than what the
citizens of the old soviet union got
they needed to get
mimeographs to get the truth and today
we need alternative media websites to
get the truth
so muslims need to get on this because
we are uh we're facing
uh a dajjal of lies coming at us and
maybe we are in the end times the akira
zaman maybe it is the time of dajal
i i don't know but it's we're certainly
overwhelmed by lies from official
sources
and the people of the lie are opposed
you know they hate the people of the
truth
and i think they recognize that uh that
real muslims people who are genuinely
faithfully practicing islam
are people of the truth and uh it's a
threat to their agenda
and you know we only get into the threat
to the bankers agenda of
our opposition to usury as muslims there
are so many reasons that islam
is a problem for these very powerful
psychopaths who rule the world
and we need to be aware of that and when
these facets come to us with alarming
news we should ascertain the truth
this is part of our deen it is so
beautifully thank you so much
dr kevin for being with us and uh
sharing
your thoughts with us on this uh new
emergence
of the new person that's been propped up
to create some hysteria and
you know so we kind of dismantle that uh
thank you i really appreciate it well
thank you for your great work eddie
where people can if they want to find
you
more of you my website is truthjihad.com
and i also write for crescent
international which is the best
current affairs muslim news magazine
thank you so much may god almighty allah
bless you reward you
thank you and if you like this episode
of the dean show
like this video share this video far and
wide
and support us on our patreon page so we
can continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
right now